[Music]
this is where ruben james feels at home
[Music]
in front of a piano working with a band
but last year he had just a handful of
gigs
it's been the toughest year of my career
so far
most of a musician's income comes from
live gigs and touring
all of my gigs from last year got
cancelled
so and they've been pushed to 2021 but
that's still a great cloud
surrounding that
and it's not just musicians who are out
of work but thousands of others who are
part of the industry
from venue owners to sound engineers
lighting crew to bath staff
the live music industry which generates
billions of pounds for the economy in
normal times
is now asking for help demanding a rough
date for when they can get back to full
capacity
and targeted financial support we're
going to be measuring our future in a
matter of months we have some reserves
but you know this is an expensive
defensive organisation even to keep
closed
the promoting sector needs to have
confidence that it can make the
transition from
close to open that needs to be
underwritten in some way
the government should be considering an
insurance government-backed insurance
policy to make that happen
many who are out of work weren't
eligible for government support either
and were protesting outside parliament
last summer the organizer warns
now there's an extra problem of brexit
we're desperate for the government to
take this seriously maybe in the form of
some kind of um
culture and creative passport that you
can have for a you know
allows you to work for say a year at a
time
you know rather than it being a
situation which would be dreadfully
difficult to negotiate where every
single person had to negotiate with
every single country
live music was one of the first sectors
to close
the industry fears how much of it will
be left when it's finally safe for the
audiences to return
milana vassalinovic sky news